welcome to a new video demokritos from
Brazil I'd like to do something else for
a change try them try the London but I'm
trying to play it a bit differently not
the usual manner this is an interesting
way to to play this opening let's see
I'm threatening on c7 and I've see I
have seen this idea before and it's it's
interesting Queen d4 but there's quindi
for sometimes you can still play just
eat six though hmm i think i'm confusing
lines the one I was thinking of how to
be 6 plate okay no worries I mean this
is still interesting the knight on d5 is
irritating for black and germ let's see
what he's doing
quindi for threatening Queen takes d5
was my original idea oh I know it's hmm
hmm six at least he's playing e6 a bit
passive but kind of kind of benefit from
that some way maybe I wonder you will
probably play Bishop d7 soon attacking
here can I can I open up the position
somehow like was c4 on something a 3
then b4 and c4 a3 Bishop d7 now maybe I
try that Bishop d7 Assad 24 maybe
maybe it's nothing it's nothing great
anyway but it's still interesting queen
deform now he might take on c2 actually
okay but I need you I need to play now
not spent spent more time maybe he can
take here I mean that that's may be
possible one thing I was intending was
96 but after 96 Bishop p6 Bishop p6
that's ninety four with a double attack
on F to enter bishop maybe he can really
take but it's possible bit of a gamble
hmm he didn't and now it's interesting I
can all all capture so you had the beep
the benighted capture doesn't make much
sense but capturing with the night and
the porn both make sense I take with the
pawn I think it's better because it
control would see 5 hmm so the night on
a 6 really AM has no big big purpose and
maybe simply clay right e6 check next
gaining probably gaining the bishop down
yeah that's a nice position
maybe you should consider 94 covering g6
yeah interesting interesting with how to
proceed okay I'll play some some normal
moves trying to catch up on the clock a
bit the knight on d5 is always an
annoying piece it that's a control g5 it
always attacks a seven so he has some
issues with that the rook always gots
this and cannot play Knight be a Jew 297
hmm so this is his idea hmm yeah can I
get rid of this night i was thinking
95-foot let's do that maybe he
remembered he can maybe you just play 8h
6m and I would have been interesting
just age 6 okay all right let's continue
gain some space all night h5 is a good
move now attacking age form mmm no
that's bad okay here's some other idea
now this is not you can still go on at
age 50 yeah ok what you did is a bit
passive but not not bad per se and I
have g5 coming the bishop on d3 is just
very strong g six maybe
we are trying to undermine e6 I've got
this this check here but it's not not
decisive or anything maybe I need the
file probably rookie one is 635 maybe
yeah maybe that yeah it still has chat
valid solid defensive position rook g1
Scott rock g8 okay f4 f5 mm-hmm that's
not much really it's nice but it's not
really big substantial edge now I can go
to see five maybe reroute it
check oh this should win a bond really
I can really take here in place c4 with
two passes okay just push the pawns that
should win really yeah to collected
passes when reality they don't check
check hmm direct mate oh yeah I don't
see it check check check check check
check mate yeah there was always a bit
of something but it feels like I should
have had some some chances rod here it
was it was ok but now now f3 is real
lemon because of later night h5 I should
do something else here maybe just 9 26
cm this is a good good spot to do that
yeah this is good just gaining the
bishop pair of course it's still nothing
spectacular but two bishops and this was
really a bad move because of this end
the night h5 here
computer is not just playing that and
not taking here why check ah because the
pieces here in trouble Wow interesting
it wants to go to we ate though
attacking here what's so great about
that here and then it once ah now that's
cute it wins the a porn like that
threatening a six ah ah that's difficult
to see threatening a six and after a4a
693 is winning this poor not that poor
that pod yep that's cute okay
interesting and this this was played and
now i'm slightly for choice and the aunt
is somehow is somehow crumbled yeah here
i can probably play more precisely yeah
exactly here i can go King f2 first this
is much better why take yeah this is
much better I can increase the pressure
first and first taking King takes a loud
rook h8 and this is obviously not
possible now yeah this is very good for
white yet it will be typical case of
releasing the tension too early I just
took it here too quickly on the f07
that's much better something like that
coming okay thanks for watching